is the chief exec
andrew haynes say hello mr haines thanks
for joining us on the program this
morning another day another strike what
you're going to do about it
well we have put a very good deal on the
table eight percent over two years no
compulsory redundancy guarantee
additional benefits to staff and their
family members
and we think the right thing to do now
is to put that to a vote of my staff
and that's the way that this will get
called off because when people see that
deal
i believe that they will recognize it's
a good deal and it's also a fair deal
because it doesn't ask taxpayers to pay
more and it doesn't ask for fair payers
passengers to pay more either
but it is a real cut
isn't it
well it's not everything everybody would
want of course it's not but what we've
tried to do is be creative we've looked
at the range of things that the rmt have
said they're concerned about so it is
eight percent over two years and it's
got that critical no compulsory
redundancy guarantee so it gives a
commitment of jobs to people and i think
job security matters a lot and it gives
discounted travel which you know many
colleagues of mine in network have said
they've wanted for 20 30 years so when
you're looking in the round i think it's
a really good deal for them
uh you see it's tricky isn't it i mean
you you earn an absolute fortune don't
you compare to a lot of people that work
for you and they'll be standing on that
picket line saying it's all right for
him fat cat
yeah well look this isn't about my pay
that was it this is about the fact that
uh we have a costly living crisis in
this country but we also have a shift in
how people are using the railway there's
a big two billion pound hole because
passengers are working work from home
much more they're doing less business
travel and we can either bridge that by
being more efficient or we can say
taxpayer pay more or we can say whack up
fares i think we should do the self-help
and actually create a more efficient
railway and then we can give job
security then we can give better pay
rises in due course and we can have a
thriving railway for the economy of
britain
yeah but you say it's not about your
payroll your pay but you know 600 000
pounds as opposed to somebody getting 25
000 pounds you can see why they might be
a little bit upset about that
i i can
but it's not about my pay but look i've
led from the front i've taken a
significant reduction compared to any of
my predecessors and during the pandemic
i
took a voluntary temporary pay cut so
like we shouldn't get distracted by that
because if i was paid nothing it
wouldn't change this deal
but i can absolutely demonstrate i'm
leading from the front in taking and
taking that pain i'm not asking any of
my colleagues to do that what i'm saying
is let's come up with a fair deal that
actually works for people the people of
britain as well as my colleagues in
network royale
do you think that trade let's put it to
the vote i mean why not put in the vote
sure do you think that trade unions have
too much power
i think it's really wrong that when we
come up with a package like that we
listen to them we spend months and
months talking to them and we try to
deal with all the different issues that
the people within network rail
then don't get a chance to vote and
that's what i think is fundamentally
wrong when we put a fair deal on the
table surely in a democratic country
people should get the chance to choose
whether or not to accept it or not
so you do think that trade unions have
too much power
well i
yes in the extent i do in the in the
extent to which that uh they are able to
reject those sort of deals without even
consulting
my staff that feels to me to be wrong
um yesterday we had um the chief
secretary to the treasury simon clark on
the program we were talking about this
and he told me that strikes are a police
politicized attempt to make capital do
you agree
so i didn't quite catch the the uh the
quote sorry could you say it again
absolutely um it's noisy where you are
this morning it was the chief secretary
to the treasury and that's um simon
clark and he said on the programme
yesterday that strikes are a politicized
attempt to make capital and i'm asking
whether you agree with him sir
look look i think uh
there are look there is a reality of a
cost of living crisis in this country so
i don't think i'm not saying that there
isn't a real need to come up with a fair
pay deal what i would say is the goal
posts keep moving and every time we get
to the point of thinking we've reached a
settlement or reaching a milestone
the rmt walk away that is a fact twice
now we've come very close
to making real progress and then they
walk away at the last minute i'm not
going to judge their motives but i can
talk from my experience we've met a lot
of their needs and yet we don't seem to
be making progress you have to ask them
what motivates them okay
i did actually um he was on the program
a little bit earlier on mick lynch um
what have you actually offered them
so we've offered eight percent over two
years we've offered no compulsory
redundancy guarantee we've offered
deeply discounted travel for colleagues
and their
and their families we've offered cash
bonuses
uh you know it's a very comprehensive
package of course it's not everything
that people would want but i think when
you look at it in the round it really
meets the fundamental needs and also by
the way it guarantees no changes to
terms and conditions the rmt have been
saying we're looking to rip up people's
terms and conditions
that is a lie we are not making any
changes to terms and conditions we've
said we will not ask people to do
anything they're not already contracted
to do
do you think if you weren't negotiating
with mick lynch you might have got it
over the line by night
no i doc i don't think this is about the
personalities i think it's about i think
it's about the wider dynamics within the
rmt